do that kind of rebounding finishing the
defensive exchange
i played with terry porter clyde drexler
they did the same
averaging just over 13. that time ran
for himself and for tobias tobias was
the one with the ball in his hands
pio with the answer highly valued hockey
assist yes and that's the laker
old school with shaquille o'neal kind of
offense beal again
with an answer batiste thiebel with the
unenviable assignment of dealing with
bradley beal who was after his own miss
i'll tell you what
that is fighting the good fight shot
goes up from veal
watch it thanks one to it wow
that's pretty remarkable he's actually
got to it twice you just said it mark it
was an important thing that you just
said the fact that it's what almost nine
minutes into this ball game a guy like
him
would have been a little bothered by the
fact that he hasn't shot yet as beall
answers
again and the floor felt like he got
fouled you can see him pleading his case
right now
as beal from the corner well embiid has
only
one point he's over six from the floor
the good news is the sixers
are clicking anyway he's got two we got
bradley beal on the floor back by ben
simmons because joelle ran the floor
pinned back his guy and been obliged
here at wells fargo center where his
team has not lost a game since december
of what you 2019 to increase your
percentages is you get
high percentage shot that time joelle
not being denied
all the way to the cup look at this dude
i can't glass and here the shot goes up
and somehow beal the smaller of shoulder
slumped
completely dejected i don't blame this
dude
11 of 13 nearly 85 percent
that's the third time early on as beall
answers again that the
76ers have hit 70s richarl missing his
first six shots
from the floor in this game seven of his
next nine after that is beale
continues to do his thing this is
getting scary now bradley beal with 35.
trump got a little bounce pass to him
it'll give joelle time to catch it as
beale turns the corner brian with a nice
screen
lead at 14.
field now and b trying to lasso him
37 points for bradley beal
that's how you're allowed those after
making a few beal
leaking not once but twice now he's tied
a season high of 39 and doc rivers
didn't want to see that
sixers exploding speaking of quarters
for 49
in that second quarter they carried that
lead
well into the third
get any more securities than that going
via russia
to come back to the nba well now it's
getting ridiculous
beale hits the three and he's fouled he
will go to the line looking for his 45th
point of the game be a season high well
you can see
ish keeping that dribble alive v ala
steve nash from under the basket
finds bradley beal shoulder square i'm
reminded when michael jordan played and
he would come into philly and you'd say
to yourself
mike's going to score 50 and the sixers
are going to win it could be one of
those nights
pose the theory that that was one of the
reasons why they were off to such a good
start
sixers only lost coming with embiid out
of the lineup losing to cleveland
have we mentioned bradley bill at all
tonight but there's 48 points including
seven of eight from beyond
having fitz trying to stop this dude
who's just rolling
[Music]
now he's gonna give himself 50.
there it is they're three minutes to
play third quarter
looks like he caught a piece of tobias
there
ps 52 for bradley beal
a history of right leg issues
now as if he doesn't have enough he is
going to the line here to shoot
still trailing by 13.
[Applause]
here's beale racing against maxie lays
it in
little knock down
meantime a career high 56 now
make it 57. the deliberate pump fake
convincing enough
well embiid now locking on the beal it's
for two
got it adding to his career high
give him 59 over the extra point watch
this it's a little breakdown
the little side step creates enough
space
that's pretty i don't know that right
foot is he touching the line i wanted to
and then presumably missed the second
well i can tell you
that it's a deflating feeling to score
that many points and still
be on the losing team that night
[Applause]
the miss goes after that miss and in
doing so
crashes to the wood and that will do it
no whistle
the game ends and the sixers win a wild
one tonight